yeah Mitchell now and double figures
although he's shooting through such is
not good as I was just saying Whiteside
no Mason has it buddy
bombs away and the Kings have a 74-62
lead every single time you got to create
your own energy in this good buddy he'll
and a chance for a four-point play for
buddy as the Kings we take the lead
right out of the timeout great play
drawn up by coach Yeager's buddy pulls
up knocks it down
I don't dos tres What's Wrong good pick
by Costa Koufos to free up buddy his
third basket 78 65 buddy plays the
powers on
anything but at 3 here stolen by supper
what defense buddy here
and then right here just jump with the
hands you kick the ball up the floor and
guess what you find mr. love quarterly
the bench comes in and gives them that
pace but it he'll watch sequence that
was that jumps into a four point play
[Applause]
great thanks by Fox right there grant to
get a hand on that shot buddy is feeling
it that's ten everybody hill and the
kings hand their largest lead of the
game
[Applause]
deep three is good for Buddy hield and
he has 17 tough shots but we are talking
about well spread the love but in love
that's big 74-66 board in this game in
eight minutes which is very unusual
won't last the long oh boy
[Applause]
55:48 but he heals deep three but what's
what's faculty gonna do if he catches
that while creating the turnover and
they give it right back
good hustle right there by Harry Giles
getting back on defense 34 3 it's almost
automatic isn't it Kingston to stop Fox
Fox back for buddy to Chicago buddy
hield
well that's two he's missed just like
that box there is stopping what would
have been a short basket by Randle a
lead for buddy Hill dear
Fox does it again and then how quickly
he looks up the floor dogs yes
anticipation right there my mr. deer and
Fox a single will do but the Kings are
looking for a home run
[Applause]
over the field wall grant
look at this past that thing is on a
rope right there buddy hield reach up
knock down and one may be the success
for the kinks at home has just pulled
out by 19 every game
tough shot but we are talking about
buddy he'll take a look at buddy here
look crossover step back Bobby chicks
48:39 buddy hield welch automatic right
now that's five of five for Buddy hield
[Music]
bit of the careless pass right there by
the errand because they are so good on
the defensive end give up to score three
102 98 turn their sprinkler systems on
buddy hield is on fire
Durant freeing up bullies dying knocked
it away into the hands of Polk Ghana
vich five point game box to the red hot
buddy hield good eye on that matchup in
the paint look at Harry you've learned
so fast threat and Buddy hield makes it
a 20-point game buddy big basket that
may do it right there 102 294 and they
show it Hornets take a timeout
[Applause]
another three for buddy he'll that's
just important buddy to put it up to
four yeah look at buddy yankem why don't
you buddy
gentlemen thank him tell them take that
which
[Applause]
yes but he gets the basketball bobbles
it a little bit doesn't lose his poise
puts it back down on the floor reaches
up that is a one leg or take it dagger
buddy hield for uno dos tres well I'll
tell you this you can say the Sacramento
Kings dispersed with this game but you
know what they won the game they stole
the game where the defender cannot get
the basketball turn to sprinkler systems
on fire
feels funny to take the lead back and
it's
great player and his best I'll put you
see there's buddy hield
[Music]
[Applause]
right back river right back
thank goodness for buddy hield the sign
did not catch it cleanly excellent
answer what did you
and he's got 14 commenting on that
you're right so that's when the Kings
played their best back Lee with this
effort poked at it kept it alive
buddy he'll get one of those ports to
Marvin Bagley buddy hield he is wide
open
swish oh boy time out Benford but he is
back
[Applause]
there's one so that's the first of the
game for Buddy hield
[Applause]
the situation
they got this team hanging on the ropes
right to you yes they do
and they're continuing to push the ball
pull up buddy Oh
he does a little bit of everything he
continues to grow as a player now he
picks up ups which jumper
[Applause]
we looked at in the sit-up ask me that
wrong but he said I got this bus has
been demands
good defense by offering plenty of time
buddy at deep three
it's raining
right now fantastic play you see buddy
pulling up
that's his ain't always seen Dodson make
the lad but he's missed two three
I'll tell you I don't know if that's the
worst defense I've ever seen in my life
but it's pretty close you can get on a
little roll here pair of these often
good offense times with some stops Oh
buddy he'll start they beat up here in
Beantown
[Applause]
but he trying to tie the game he's not
going away and he's been the 35 kind of
minute guy and I totally agree with that
I think they're watching you flail off
and lately as we see buddy buckets the
Holy Spirit oh yeah we're absolutely we
need to know I mean we don't miss games
or flight that buddy Hill but he didn't
miss open threes tough matchup there
that's the guy you want I say just get
the ball to buddy he'll what a job
defensively by cauley-stein box off to
the races
he's got teammates with him buddy for
the lead buddy hield comes to Dallas
Texas and at the moment hits the biggest
shot of the game oh boy does the
basketball buddy
downtown timeout Mavericks
[Applause]
[Music]
nice pass to buddy hield corner three
left foot work my buddy there I'm down
back-to-back threes oh oh look at that
turn your back step back
[Applause]
bunny hill ties the game
and the Kings if they get better on the
perimeter defense and keep that guy in
front of us we see plenty knocked down
another three ball is altered gained one
in Kanter and CJ McCollum and Damian
Lillard have been as good as it wants to
get us to his seam but he just keeps
rising the plane most of them at a very
high level
[Music]